rupert murdoch is one of the biggest
media moguls in the world
and a billionaire worth 19 billion
dollars
known for owning fox news he also owns
the wall street journal the times of
london and a series of broadcast
networks
and if donald trump wants to get into
the media business after he leaves
office
as has been speculated he could learn a
thing or two from the media mogul
rupert murdoch's media empire began in
australia
with one small newspaper he inherited
from his father he started building that
um into an
empire by a twofold strategy one was to
sell controversy and scandal and one was
to buy up his competitors he's kind of
the king of acquisitions in the media
space
by 1985 he built a portfolio big enough
to land him on the forbes 400.
1985 was the first and last time donald
trump
outranked rupert murdoch on the forbes
400.
that year donald trump was listed with a
fortune of 600 million dollars
but he didn't deserve the ranking he had
created a fake persona to fool
forbes into believing his father had
transferred all his wealth to him
around the late 80s murdoch realized the
future of media was in television
so he bought a series of stations in the
u.s that would become the fox
broadcasting company
as well as sky news in the uk his bet
paid off in 1998 when
fox's entertainment arm went public
pulling in 2.8 billion dollars and
adding 1.7 billion dollars to murdoch's
net worth
trump eventually made a comeback in 1996
he returned to the forbes 400.
he struck gold in the early 2000s with
the apprentice which he later claimed to
provided him 214 million dollars
in earnings but he did not reinvest that
wisely he bought
up a series of golf horses and resorts
that ended up kind of just being money
pits
trump's latest miscalculation actually
came in 2016.
he held on to his business empire while
he became president
and since then his fortune has declined
by an estimated one billion dollars
while trump has been losing money over
the course of his presidency
murdoch has flourished not only have the
ratings of his conservative fox news
jumps but he also took advantage of the
anti-regulatory climate
to make the deal of a lifetime in 2018
he agreed to sell 21st century fox's
movie studio
a handful of cable networks and it
stakes in star india and hulu to disney
for 71.3 billion dollars
donald trump's 2016 presidential run
benefited from positive news coverage
from fox news
however this summer saw the relationship
between trump and fox news sour
fox polls showed the president behind
the democrat nominee joe biden
and on election night fox news called
arizona for biden before
anyone else now trump has been favoring
the rivals
newsmax and oan for a long time trump
has been saying that when he leaves the
white house he's going to go into media
that has always been the most successful
industry for him he was way better at
hosting the apprentice than he is at
running a
real estate empire and it was kind of
expected that he'd go into partnership
with fox news maybe he'd have a show on
the air
um that does not look like it's
happening anytime soon
and there's even talks of a trump
network to rival fox
maybe he'll go into a partnership with
oan or newsmax
maybe he'll start a digital network no
one's really sure what he's actually
going to do
but it's looking like he will not be
teaming up with fox news